[Musik]
guten abend herzlich willkommen maybritt
ist heute marietta aber keine sorge wir
gehen fest davon aus dass die nächste
woche wieder endlich negativ getestet
ist und sie hier alles vertraute
gastgeberinnen wieder begrüßen kann
unser thema heute liegt auf der hand und
am tag gleich drei gipfeltreffen heute
zum krieg in der ukraine und us
präsident joe biden ist zu besuch in
europa nato und eu sortieren sich ein
krieg in europa bei dem der westen
mitmischt aber bisher nur von der
seitenlinie aus wie weit geht der westen
und wie weit geht putin und wie groß ist
die gefahr dass hier ungewollt 1 1
weltkrieg entfesselt wird
schwierige fragen viel zu besprechen
heute mit diesen gästen
alexander rodney ans gegen der
wirtschaftsberater des ukrainischen
präsidenten sagt ein komplettes öl- und
gas-embargo würde die russische
kriegsmaschine stoppen
florence gaub für die
sicherheitsexperten haben die ukraine
eine echte chance diesen krieg zu
gewinnen
constanze stelzenmüller von der
us-denkfabrik brookings institution sagt
die nukleare bedrohung russlands müssen
wir ernst nehmen
katarina barley für die vize-präsidentin
des europa-parlaments steht fest putin
hat nicht erwartet dass der westen so
geschlossen ist
und norbert reske der cdu-außenpolitiker
befürchtet dieser krieg wird länger
dauern
sie sind zu gast bei marietta slomka
und ich freue mich sehr dass wir alle
hier sind danke fürs kommt herr retten
jansky würde gerne bei ihnen beginnen
wenn man sich ihrem lebenslauf an sind
landen school of economics dann in
princeton studiert dann eine professur
assistentin assistenten professur in
cambridge also lauter eliteuniversitäten
sie sind wirtschaftsberater das dann neu
gewählten präsidenten sind es geworden
das ist zwar ein lebenslauf der bereitet
einen eigentlich nicht darauf vor in
talkshows zu sitzen und über patriot
raketen zu sprechen ja ganz genau das
werde ich mir auch nicht vorstellen
können ich gesagt aber so sollten einmal
die zeiten und wir müssen uns einsetzen
für unser land wir müssen unser land
retten und wir sind leider auch alle zu
militärexperten geworden mittlerweile in
anführungsstrichen natürlich so ist das
habe ihn anspricht ich jetzt aus der
jetzt geflüchtet sind das ist auch schon
bei uns nebenan wohnt jetzt einmal eine
junge ukrainerin die zeigt mir dann
jeden tag fotos und sagt guck mal das
ist bei mir um die ecke da hab ich
gewohnt unter das war das café in dem
wir uns immer getroffen haben wie gehen
sie damit um dass jetzt in ihre
heimatstadt solche bilder kommen also
haben sie das eigentlich richtig fassen
kann oder ist diese ungläubigkeit die
uns glaube ich alle immer noch auch
projekt auch bei ihnen natürlich also
wir sind schon mittendrin wir müssen
damit zurechtkommen
es ist schockierend ich habe auch ganz
viele geschichten eigene geschichten
ähnlich sind ich könnte jetzt alle
erzählen muss jetzt nicht sein aber es
ist natürlich ein ja für herren der
zustand in dem sich unser land befindet
und wir müssen diesen krieg so schnell
wie möglich zu ende führen und zu
unseren gunsten ihn gewinnen und wir
müssen noch verstehen dass mit diesem
regime das diesen krieg begonnen hat
langfristig keinen frieden zu machen ist
und das ist ganz wichtig zu verstehen
aber diese fragen kann man diesen krieg
gewinnen dann werden wir noch reden und
sie sagten ja auch mal wird zum
waffenexperten plötzlich zwangsläufig
aber doch am anfang noch eine frage an
den wirtschaftsexperten sind ja
wirtschaftsberater des präsidenten
dieser schachzug von putin jetzt zu
sagen also gas oder öl gibt es noch wenn
der rubel rollt wie schätzen sie das ein
ja das ist schon mal symptomatisch also
ganz klar sind sie von dem schwachen
rubel die inflation als rasant
angestiegen das bereitet den sorgen das
ist ganz klein dem dem russischen regime
und da wollen sie auch gegen wirken und
das gelingt ihm auch zum teil der rubel
ist nämlich wieder stärker geworden
nachdem sie diese ansagen gemacht haben
und wir müssen natürlich aufpassen im
westen das mit allen mitteln verhindert
wird dass sie diese sanktionen umgehen
ja und das versuchen sie jetzt zu machen
und natürlich ist das einerseits ein
gutes zeichen dass die sanktionen noch
wirkt andererseits ein schlechtes
zeichen dass die auch dagegen wirken
können also das russische regime dagegen
wirken kann und da müssen wir uns aber
darauf vorbereiten diese diese meldung
von von
putins rubel schacht so wie man es so
nennen will ist eine von den aktuellen
heute am tag bevor wir über die anderen
ereignisse dieses tages und diese drei
großen gipfel reden schauen wir uns das
erst noch mal einen bericht
zusammengefasst an was heute geschehen
ist
gestern die überraschung aus russland
putin will für energielieferungen nur
noch rubel akzeptieren so will er seine
strauchelnde währung stützen und
sanktionen aushebeln erste reaktionen
konsterniert nach unseren informationen
ist es ein verstoß gegen die privaten
verträge da diese in der regel in euro
abgewickelt werden
doch wer setzt sich durch auf gas und
öllieferungen wollen und können
deutschland und andere staaten nicht
verzichten die ukraine warnen schon vor
einem einknicken der europäer
das ist als ob man mit einer hand der
ukraine hilft und mit der anderen
russland hilft ukraine zu töten
geschlossenheit darum ging es heute beim
nato gipfel der staats und
regierungschefs in brüssel
hier befürchten sie dass russland auch
chemiewaffen einsetzen könnte
jeder einsatz chemischer waffen würde
die art des konfliktes fundamental
ändern das hätte weitreichende und harte
konsequenzen consequences mehr waffen
für die ukraine strengere sanktionen
aber keine militärische einmischung das
bleibt die linie der nato reicht das
niemand in europa nicht mal die staaten
die weiter wechseln von der russischen
grenze
sind heute noch sicher
zum schutz der nato ostflanke werden
daher vier zusätzliche kampftruppen rund
1500 soldaten stationiert
us präsident joe biden kündigte weitere
sanktionen gegen 400 russische politiker
sowie unternehmen an und machte klar
die nato war noch nie so gut wie heute
putin hat mit dem einmarsch in die
ukraine genau das gegenteil von dem
erreicht was er erreichen wollte
einigkeit geschlossenheit das sind die
worte die man da heute glaube ich am
häufigsten gehört hat frau stelzenmüller
die sicht der usa das zu beiden hierhin
gekommen ist und sogar dem eu gipfel
teilnimmt was für ein signal wäre die
us-regierung damit senden also man muss
ja sagen dass diese amerikanische
regierung nach einem eigentlich nach dem
außenpolitischen fehlstart in dem sowohl
der
tragische afghanistan abzug der auch für
das transatlantische verhältnis eine
beinahe katastrophe darstellte stattfand
da ist auch ein wirklich verhagelten
boot geschäft das geschäft details von
hier nichts zur sache eine völlige
kehrtwende gemacht hat beschlossen hat
dass in diesem konflikt die europäer
nicht nur sozusagen
als mitläufer zum betrachten die
sozusagen durch ihre zahlen noch ein
bisschen dekoration und legitimität
hinzufügen sondern die regierung hat
begriffen in washington dass die
europäer hier
eine essentielle kriegswaffe mitbringen
nämlich die wirtschaftsmacht und die
regulierungs macht der europäischen
union ohne das wären die amerikaner
glaube ich hier bin ich sehr sehr
schwierigen lage gegenüber putin zu
bestehen insbesondere deshalb weil
niemand im westen weder die amerikaner
noch wir in europa
militärisch selber eingreifen wollen
wegen weil wir uns zum ersten mal in
einem konflikt direkt einer großmacht
mit atomwaffen gegenüber sehen und ich
erlebe dass er immer schicken wo ich
eigentlich lebe ich bin zu besuch hier
erlebe wie wirklich die amerikaner nicht
nur mit uns reden sondern in engen
führung konsultieren das bestätigen auch
europäischer politiker und
ministerialbeamten es wird alles
konsultiert jede sprachregelung jedes
detail und die maschinenräume sind
einige seit monaten im dauer gespräch
miteinander also mit den europäern quasi
auf augenhöhe absolut setzt aber doch
natürlich voraus dass die europäer dann
auch gemeinsam stehen frauen rauball
die frage für sie nach brüssel
weitergereicht tun sie das denn der man
sieht ja schon dass es da auch viele
kräfte gibt also ich denke zum beispiel
mal anderen opfern an ungarn die nicht
wollen dass sie oder er will es
jedenfalls nicht dass die waffen durch
sein territorium transportiert werden da
stellt er sich ja schon mal außen vor
hier habe das maß an geschlossenheit
innerhalb der europäischen union das ist
schon sehr beeindruckend und auch das
maß an schnelligkeit und
entschlossenheit mit dem entscheidungen
mit der entscheidung getroffen werden
gerade im bereich der außen und
sicherheitspolitik was der normalerweise
jetzt nicht zu den glanzstücken der
europäischen union gehört durch das
einstimmigkeitsprinzip durch sehr
unterschiedliche interessen also die
einigkeit ist sehr sehr groß sie ist
nicht
absolut einhellig sie haben mit turban
den ungarischen regierungschef erwähnt
der da ein doppeltes spiel betreibt er
war ja immer sehr nahe an putin dran das
haben wir auch während der korona krise
erlebte hat er das ganz demonstrativ
diese nähe noch mal gesucht und auch
demonstriert
für viktor orban war russland und auch
china auch immer ein druckmittel wenn
ihr uns jetzt gelder vorenthalten dann
besorgen wir uns die woanders
wladimir putin hat ganz gezielt versucht
da die europäische union auch zu spalten
wenn man in ungarn ist aber ich bin dort
vor gut zwei wochen gewesen dann hört
man auch in den
jeweils der orban an medien auch anti
ukrainische propaganda
was passieren so skurrile dinge wie
ungarische
europaabgeordnete stimmen im
europaparlament gegen russland sagen
aber zu hause in den staatsmedien dass
sie dafür gestimmt hätten also es ist
ungarn ist tatsächlich der unsicherer
kantonist aber im großen und ganzen ist
es eine geschlossenheit in diesem
politikfeld die man so bisher nicht
gekannt hat die osteuropäer wollen aber
zum beispiel ein bisschen weitergehen in
einigen bereichen gleichzeitig gestehen
wir herr röttgen deutschland wieder als
die verzögerung und bremser da ist das
eigentlich ganz fair denn wir zahlen zum
beispiel eine ganze menge innviertel von
diesen 500 millionen jetzt zusätzlich
gesagt man und haben offenbar auch mehr
waffen geliefert in letzter zeit als man
so wusste und und hörte
also zum einen haben wir sowieso bis zum
krieg sehr viele leistungen die ukraine
erbracht wirtschaftlich kein anderes
land hat über so viele jahre die ukraine
unterstützt wir haben auch in diesen
wenigen wochen sagen mit einer tradition
und doktrinen gebrochen also keine
waffen in konfliktgebiete nord stream 2
war jahrelang ein kontroverses thema ich
habe seit jahren über jahre dagegen
gekämpft mit anderen auf einmal dass es
innerhalb von tagen weg auch schrift
einzusetzen war für uns nicht
selbstverständlich also wir haben uns
sehr bewegt aber
der punkt heute ist nicht ist nicht
ungarn
sonder in der frage die sie auf geworfen
haben
worum geht es es geht darum dass putin
nicht gewinnt und
das ist so überragend denn wenn er
gewinnt haben wir ein anderes europa
auch für uns dann haben wir dauerhaft
teilung dann wird er wird die welt die
lehre gezogen haben krieg als mittel der
politik hat sich gelohnt und damit ist
diese methode des 19 wäre diese methode
des neunzehnten jahrhunderts im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert eingeführt wenn
man das sieht dann muss man eben
feststellen betonen nicht alles wir tun
nicht alles
und deutschland ist
zögerlich und verspricht weniger als
andere und liefert noch weniger als
versprochen bei den waffen also die
schweden ist ein 10 millionen wir haben
5000 panzerfäuste versprochen haben sie
auch geliefert haben sie noch mal 5000
versprochen die dänen
2700 und wir kommen wir versprechen
schon weniger und kommen nicht nach es
herrscht auch intransparent mal geht gar
nichts mehr dann am nächsten tag wird
wieder geliefert dann weiß man gar nicht
was es eigentlich mit der industrie wir
sind die viertgrößte volkswirtschaft wir
sind der viertgrößte waffenexporteur der
welt aber dänemark überholt und und der
2 das muss sich ändern das muss auch
transparent transparenz herrscht das
muss gesagt werden was tun wir wir sind
ja als in der zweite punkt sind die
energie
sanktionen es hängt an deutschland nicht
an ungarn es hängt an deutschland vor
allem dass bei uns der bundeskanzler
hatte wirtschaftsminister kategorisch
erklären dass das nicht geht da sind sie
beide sicher sind wir also einig doch es
geht aber wir sind uns einig und wir
finanzieren jeden tag mit sechs bis 700
millionen euro die kriegsmaschinen dann
würde jetzt herr scholz sagen ich bin
ich jetzt irgendwo sie dürfen aber der
stolz sagen wenn wir unsere
wirtschaftskraft komplett verlieren dann
werden wir diesen krieg auch nicht mehr
so finanzieren können und der ukraine so
auch nicht mehr helfen und ich würde
zwei dinge erwidern dazu erstens
ruinieren wir damit feststehen kein
ökonom behauptet dass wir unsere
wirtschaft damit ruhen indes behauptet
kein ökonom und zweitens selbst wenn ich
es denken würde würde ich es doch nicht
sagen das ist doch gerade dazu die
einladung an herrn putin genau das dann
zu machen und wenn es übrigens bei dem
rubel vorschlag bleibt sage ich ihnen
wird keine europäische regierung bereit
sein diese rechnung in rubel zu
begleichen dann könnten wir ja gleich
den den russischen soldaten ihren sold
in rubel bezahlen also es ist ja sowieso
immer offen dass putin das tut von dem
die bundesregierung sagt das ist die
katastrophe weil sie gerade darum soll
sie ist es nicht vorbereiten müssen uns
ohnehin weil sie gerade sagte man sollte
es ihnen nicht immer sagen
unsere sicherheits werks experte vor
glaubt war das eigentlich clou putin
schon vor dem einmarsch immer zu sagen
was die nato alles nicht machen wird ich
glaube ich jeden fall also ich war immer
sehr kritisch weil ich immer gedacht
habe das konzept der abschreckung das
ist das ist ein konzept das in der
internationalen politik in den theorien
diskutiert würde ich meine die atomwaffe
an sich ist ein abschreckungs waffe die
wurde nur zweimal eingesetzt 45 also ich
fand das immer sehr heikel und das dass
man ihm direkt von anfang an sagt mach
dir mal keine sorgen militärisch wird
schon nichts passieren hat ihn natürlich
schon in der hinsicht auch ermutigt nah
und deswegen ist er sich auch als
überrascht dass wir zum ersten mal sagen
die moment jetzt hast du zum ersten mal
da eine rote linie überschritten wurde
heute eine rote linie gezogen bei diesem
gipfel
ich hätte sie nicht so recht gehört also
ich hab jetzt auch mal ist es noch im
ohr der sagte wir definieren sie nicht
also es gibt die überlegung wenn
weiterhin mit diesem nuklearen narrativ
so gespielt werden also dass wir mit der
angst ich sags ja immer wieder nicht die
bombe ist die waffe sondern die angst
vor der bombe ist die waffe also dass
man das immer wieder sagt und auch gerne
so verklausuliert wie auch mit jeweils
jetzt wieder dann sofort einer nuklearen
dystopie und albtraum welt redet es geht
einfach nur darum immer wieder das wort
nuklear und in den kopf zu setzen das
wird nie explizit gesagt wir behalten
uns das vor die bombe einzusetzen aber
man könnte natürlich eine rote linie
irgendwann ziehen und sagen ganz
explizit sagen wenn ihr das macht dann
müsst ihr auch mit einem gegenschlag
rechnen das machen wir bisher nicht weil
wir auf diese spiele nicht eingehen das
finde ich vielleicht auch gar nicht so
unklug aber das könnte man machen wenn
mit dieser rhetorik weiterhin so
fahrlässig gespielt werden wenn sie
jetzt schon beim thema atomwaffen sind
es ist eben auch diese bedrohung die
nicht nur kommt dass es mit einem
akw-unfall geben könnte hat der herr
poroschenko hatte der frühere präsident
der ukraine der folgende von herrn
selensky gestern im heute journal gesagt
er habe ja eine schlechte nachricht für
deutsche politiker sie seien eigentlich
bereits im krieg dazu musste man sich
nur vorstellen wie sich eben einen
solchen einem reaktorunfall beim
attackierten atomkraftwerk wie sich das
für ganz europa auswirken würde aber
diese direkte drohung oder implizite
trugen wir setzen eventuell auch
taktische nuklearwaffen
ist dann auch mal einen schritt weiter
reden wir jetzt gleich darüber gucken
uns aber eben noch mal an wie sich das
zwischen im überblick darstellt
wladimir putin spielt mit der angst des
westens
droht gleich zu kriegsbeginn mit seinen
atomwaffen
wer auch immer versucht uns zu stoppen
oder unser land und seine leute bedroht
sollte wissen russlands reaktion wird
sofort erfolgen und zu konsequenzen für
sie führen wie sie sie noch nie in ihrer
geschichte erlebt haben
putin löst die erste bereitschaft stufe
seines atomarsenals aus die einen sind
beeindruckt ich bin sicher wenn putin
mit dem rücken an der wand steht und da
nichts mehr passiert und insofern muss
man krisenmanagement betreiben dann
könnte er versucht zahlen zur atomaren
eskalation zu schreiten ja das ist eine
gefahr in der wir leben die anderen
sorgen sich nicht
da schrillen alle alarmglocken und da
muss man ganz einfach sagen so weit sind
wir noch nicht aber der faktische
vorgang das was passiert ist ist nichts
was uns jetzt in angst und schrecken
versetzen muss doch das russische
atomarsenal ist mächtig und mit
6255 nuklearsprengköpfen der nato mit
ihren insgesamt
6.065 sprengköpfen überlegen
und mit den neuen hyperschall raketen
legen putins atomwaffen angeblich 1000
kilometer in nur fünf minuten zurück
eine ernste bedrohung für europa
kann man sich das anhört und ansieht
dann kann einem angst und bange werden
aber sie vor aussagen genau das ist
eigentlich auch der zweck ich glaube
dass man nicht vergessen wir haben wir
gerade gesehen dass da die atome
verglichen wurden in zahlen krieg ist
kein fußballspiel es geht nicht darum
wer hat wie viel man auf dem feld und
wann wird ein tor geschossen und dann
ist man vorbei sondern es sowohl
militärisch als auch politisch und diese
ganze psychologische dimension die angst
das spiel mit der angst ist kalkül das
heißt sobald sie angst bekommen wenn sie
das wort lu klar oder atom hören dann
hat er sein ziel erreicht das ist eine
werden manipuliert und das muss einem
klar sein das heißt wer sich vor noch
sagt denn die angst die in uns ausgelöst
wird die uns ab davon abhält skandieren
die uns davon abhält irgendwie
vielleicht eine härtere grenze zu ziehen
das ist gewollt davon daher fallen wir
jedes mal wenn wir angst bekommen genau
in seine masche rein das ist ein
bisschen das was sie auch sagen putin
bleibt
schwierig zu sagen natürlich was er vor
hat aber generell bin ich damit ihn
einfach sondern man muss auch bedenken
die russischen eliten haben jagten die
zum teil 600 bis 700 millionen dollar
kosten also anscheinend sind das
menschen die gerne leben mehr als
sterben und deswegen sie werden das
nicht so einfach aufgeben wenn das
atomwaffen geht und nuklear schläge dann
ist das wahrscheinlich eher einen bluff
an dieser stelle was aber passieren
würde sollte putin wirklich in seinem
eigenen land in gefahr kommen und seine
macht in gefragt kommen das kann keiner
genau sagen aber ich glaube an dieser
stelle ist das weit übertrieben diese
angst vor einem nokia
stelzenmüller sie
alle haben
wenn man denn jetzt an leute wie die
sicherheits expertin fiona hill denkt
die sagen doch also wir halten das
durchaus für realistisch dass das putin
so etwas macht also sprechen meine
kolleginnen wir arbeiten ja zusammen und
die kennt sozusagen wie die psychologie
der russischen führung besser als ich
nehme ihre einschätzung sehr ernst aber
lassen sie mich einfach eines außen vor
stehen bereits die drohung und selbst
die verkleidete drohung mit der
anwendung von atombomben ist ein
zivilisationsbruch
putin hat einen nachkriegs normen damit
durchbrochen damit dass er dadurch dass
er damit gedroht hat
die nordkoreaner haben gerade ihre
stärkste interkontinental rakete
getestet
zwischen diesen beiden ereignissen
besteht ein zusammenhang selbst
erstellen wir werden einfach sozusagen
die korken raus gezogen aus diesem aus
dem konsens dass wir bestimmte waffen
nicht anwenden und das ist das problem
hier deshalb ist hat sich die new york
times heute vor dem beginn des gipfels
einen anonymen amerikanischen hohen
beamten zitiert mit den worten wenn der
kreml diese waffe anwendet dein olbertz
auf dann haben wir eine neue lage und
das war eine implizite drohung damit
dass die nato sich dann vorstellen
könnte in den krieg einzutreten das soll
das nicht genau artikulieren will auf
einem gipfel ist natürlich klar weil man
will sich das vorbehalten und da einen
gewissen
gewisse priorität walten lassen aber ich
glaube ist es tatsächlich so wir haben
übrigens also man könnte dabei auch noch
biologische waffen erwähnen und
chemische waffen
wir haben ja noch ein fan von ihr sind
alle gruppen trugen auszeiten bei sogar
weltweit die die russen unterstellen ja
gerne den ukrainern dinge die sie die
sie selber machen wollen und die
dubiosen haben jetzt viel zeit damit
verbracht zu behaupten auf ihren auf
ihren kanälen dass die ukraine biowaffen
labore hätten also und und dort und die
anwendung von biowaffen verbreiten
würden was natürlich erlogen war aber
auch das lässt natürlich in brüssel und
in vorstädten eine ampel und auch in
berlin die alarmglocken hochgehen wenn
man sich dann fragt was die russen
planen insofern also wenn wenn wenn die
russen so massiv spuren auslegen
es ist glaube ich notwendig und
vernünftig sich zu überlegen wie man
reagieren oder glauben sie dass das da
das wäre dann die rote linie von der
jetzt so oft gesprochen haben ich würde
es so formulieren die vorstellten
wilders getan hat also es gibt bin auch
ihre auffassung es gibt jetzt immer noch
eine rationalität phase in der das
sprechen über die nukleare bedrohung
einschüchterung ist das glaube ich kann
man im moment zu analysieren aber es ist
ja durchaus eine entwicklung denkbar
wünschenswert dass russland und putin
militärisch immer weiter unter druck
gerät so also dass man muss jetzt kann
kein urteil haben aber es ist eher die
entwicklung moment eher kommen
gegenoffensive und juristischer mehr
bleibt stecken usw und ich und in dem ab
der phase in der putin immer stärker
auch militärisch unter druck gerät
glaube bin ich ganz sicher dass putin
nicht mehr berechenbar ist das glaube
ich wird man sagen müssen da gibt es
eher sich kenne kein der von sich sagt
ich kann ihnen dann noch berechnen für
putin geht es jetzt schon um alles oder
nichts es gibt für ihn keinen rückweg
das in dieser kombination das würde ja
dann aber auch dazu ein land zu sagen
ich mache auch ganz unfassbarer dinge
nicht ändern aber die kombination von
den nächsten schritt den weg und er ist
nicht berechenbar das ist wirklich das
ist der das spricht den gefährlichsten
nicht einschätzbaren entwicklungs punkt
in dieser tricks entwicklung an und das
was wir sage ich mal die nato dazu nur
entscheiden muss ist wir müssen uns
darauf vorbereiten
man kann da führen darüber nicht mehr
reden hat zu sagen das wird eine antwort
finden aber man nicht glaubt man kann
auch sagen diese vorbereitung hat
begonnen aber man muss diesen punkt mit
ins kalkül ziehen so bitter das ist und
so zivilisations verändert das ist der
kalte krieg war der konsens wie in
dieser drohung vereinbaren wir kriege
sind nicht mehr sind nicht mehr
verantwortbar und jetzt wird der krieg
nicht nur nicht mehr als verantwortbar
angesehen sondern aktiv geführt und in
diesem krieg wird die nukleare drohung
mit eingeführt das ist wirklich die
zivilisation zur änderung die putin
begeht und darum ist es so entscheidend
dass er nicht gewinnt denn sonst wird
das teil der realität
genau dürfte ich bin mit ihnen so 1 aber
ich frage mich nur wenn man darüber
hinaus denken also was wäre der stil
dieses dieser bombe seien meistens eine
oder sie noch chemischen waffen jährige
wurde ins logo ja wäre ja die ukraine
den ukrainischen willen zu brechen das
ist eine karte die kann man nur einmal
spielen weil wenn man einmal eine bombe
gezündet hat und die keiner sagen was
ich eine umkehr dann dann kann er die
nicht mehr spielen wissen sie wie oft
die syrische regierung chemische waffen
eingesetzt hat das was anderes 336 mal
gab keine keine kapitulation der
rebellen also deswegen ich glaube aber
auch kein eingreifen des westens in
einer linie die obama wir haben gelernt
hatte
genau aber ich sag nur die vorstellung
ist aber eine andere frage aber ich sage
nur die vorstellung dass man so eine
waffe hat mit dem man den ukrainischen
willen brechen kann das kann ja nur
einmal testen und ich weiß nicht wie sie
das sehen ich habe das gefühl der
ukrainische wille ist nicht zu brechen
und ich meine schauen sie sich die
amerikaner in vietnam die sowjetunion in
afghanistan
die bestrafung strategie stellen sie
schrecklich ist auf menschlicher ebene
führt nicht zum erfolg und da müssen
doch wir müssen nur noch mit
einkalkulieren dass nicht nur die
ukraine sondern vielleicht auch der
westen der adressat ist einsatzes einer
taktischen nuklearwaffe ist auch an uns
wurde ja die frage gestellt
ist das jetzt hab ich jetzt deutlich
genug gemacht dass ihr besser aussteigt
an der stelle wird orientiert sind als
adressaten also wir reden hier über
schrecklich und bei der letzten ist
natürlich bei istanbul die ukraine in
den westen ist er wäre der adressat wenn
es zu diesem unvorstellbaren verbrechen
berlin verstehen sie das denn heute von
seiten des westens offen der nato gesagt
wird ein einsatz zum beispiel von
chemiewaffen würde sehr ernste
konsequenzen haben was kann man denn
überhaupt noch drauflegen
na ja zunächst mal ist dieser ganze
krieg auch an den westen gerichtet das
ist ja ein krieg gegen unsere form zu
leben gegen freiheit gegen demokratie
gegen menschenrechte gegen
rechtsstaatlichkeit das war es von
anfang an und dass putin geglaubt hat er
könne diesen krieg innerhalb von wenigen
tagen durchziehen die ukraine überrennen
und dann im grunde genommen als der
klare sieger hervorgehen und dann
vielleicht in ein paar jahren mit dem
nächsten land weiter machen das zeigt ja
welchen welches mindset er da hatte das
ist eine demonstration dass er freiheit
und rechtsstaatlichkeit und demokratie
in seinem direkten umfeld auch als
vorbild für seine eigene gesellschaft
nicht duldet
die rote linie diskussion ja ich bin da
immer ein bisschen gespalten weil ich
weil ich finde in dem wir jetzt eine
halbe stunde darüber diskutieren machen
wir schon ein bisschen seinen job also
das ist ja die szenarien die man sich da
vorstellen kann sind entsetzlich putin
ist unberechenbar wenn er in die ecke
gedrängt ist nur was ist eben die
konsequenz für uns die konsequenz ist
dass in den
militär führungsetagen den politischen
führungsetagen dieses szenario
genauestens durchgespielt werden muss
und dann klar sein muss was dann
passiert das wird aber mit sicherheit
nicht öffentlich diskutiert werden und
das ist auch gut und richtig so es muss
klar sein für putin das
heftige konsequenzen folgen und ich
glaube dass er sicher sehr verschätzt
hat in diesem krieg es kam ja sehr früh
schon die signale werden heftige
konsequenzen kommen und es sind sehr
heftige konsequenzen gefreut also
persönliche bei den personenbezogenen
sanktionen finanzpolitische
wirtschaftspolitische militärische also
dass das ganze arsenal an reaktion durch
den westen das hat putin ja massiv
überrascht insofern
können wir eine gewisse hoffnung darein
legen dass er solche warnungen die jetzt
ausgesprochen werden auch ernster nimmt
als er das vielleicht am anfang des
krieges oder der ganzen krise getan hat
sie schaut mich so an ich
habe eine etwas dunklere sicht der dinge
und zwar ganz ohne die die debatte mit
massenvernichtungswaffen
ich
glaube wir haben in den letzten wochen
uns an den gedanken gewöhnt dass dieser
konflikt länger dauern könnte und an die
vorstellung dass die ukraine einfach ist
sich immer weiter wären und wenn wir
ihnen helfen dann würden werden die
russen weiter schwächeln und ich bin mir
nicht sicher dass das richtig ist wir
müssen zum einen einfach immer wieder
bedenken dass unsere informationen über
das was tatsächlich auf dem schlachtfeld
passiert unvollständig sind und die
ukraine machen eine wirklich großartige
informationsarbeit und die russen machen
eine sehr schlechte die propaganda der
russin das ist wirklich cool das heißt
ich glaube man sollte bei der
einschätzung davon ausgehen dass es den
russen vielleicht etwas besser geht als
wir denken und der ukraine vielleicht
etwas schlechter außerdem die russen die
russen können material nachtleben bei
den ukrainern das hängt von uns so und
da wissen wir was wir probleme haben und
da gibt es einen konkreten punkt auf
denen wir achten müssen und das ist dass
die russen
versuchen auf teufel komm raus jetzt
sich auf der saar an zu schießen
unter anderem mit mit raketen die sie
von die von schiffen aus abschätzen so
die ukraine haben kaum
raketen mit denen sie dagegen sich
wehren weil sie heute nach eigenen
angaben ein schiff versenkt haben ja
aber dass damit ist dieses ist die
schlacht noch nicht gewonnen ein und ich
nur darauf hinweisen wenn wenn wenn es
den russen gelänge oder einzunehmen dann
würden zwei dinge passieren erstens
werden die ukraine dann vom schwarzen
meer abgeschnitten und damit von den
hafen von wo 50 prozent der ukrainischen
import und export reinkommen korrigieren
sie mich gerne wenn das falsch ist und
das andere ist damit stehen dann die
russen vor voll moldawien damit ist dann
tatsächlich eine neue lage da damit
wären wir noch befinden wir uns in einem
zustand wo kiew und moskau angeblich
miteinander verhandelt ich glaube die
die käfer regierung von herr präsident
soll es geben mit gutem willen die
russen mit deutlich weniger ich glaube
ich traue den keinen zentimeter das
dient meiner ansicht nach zum zeitgewinn
aber ein fall von besser wäre wäre eine
veränderung der lage die plötzlich die
ukrainische regierung in eine
verzweifelte position bringen würde und
es gilt glaube ich zunächst mal darum
also auf ganz konventionellem wege zu
verhindern dass das passiert und da ist
viel zu tun sind sie denn mit dem was
dann heute auch zugesagt wurde an
weiteren lieferungen zufrieden in
anführungsstrichen wil sg war ja auch
beim nato-treffen zugeschaltet und hat
erstaunlicherweise panzer gefordert aber
er hat überhaupt nicht mehr über die no
fly seien also gar diese flugverbotszone
gesprochen wie ist das zu interpretieren
ja weil wir mittlerweile verstehen dass
es unwahrscheinlich ist dass sie
eingeführt wird das heißt aber natürlich
nicht dass wir uns nicht wünschen ist
mir natürlich eine gute lösung aber wir
brauchen dennoch nach wie vor
luftabwehrsysteme die wir nicht haben
brauchen panzer die front ist
mittlerweile eingefroren also da kommen
weder die juristen noch wir weiter das
ist auch zum teil weil wir keine
angriffswaffen haben wir sonst fielen
die panzer und vielen die kanonen uns
fehlen zum teil auch die munition viel
und da brauchen wir nach wie vor
nachschub und es liegen auch listen vor
dass der staat also in deutschland weiß
man darüber bescheid deswegen ich würde
auch jetzt ein bisschen zurückgreifen
wollen auch das was frau wie gesagt hat
ich finde man dürfe auf keinen fall sich
zufrieden geben mit dem was bis jetzt
gemacht wurde erstens putin passt sich
anja der russische anführer passt sich
an die sanktionen die schon eingeführt
wurden und es gelingt ihm auch zum teil
deswegen der druck muss weiter steigen
das handelsembargo auf öl und gas ist
nach wie vor nicht eingeführt worden und
damit finanziert sich und der russische
staat diesen krieg und solange das nicht
geschieht kommt diese kriegsmaschine
auch nicht zum stillstand deswegen nach
wie vor wir brauchen militärische
unterstützung und da besteht eine reelle
gefahr dass wir das vielleicht nicht
weiter halten können wenn das nicht
weiter passiert dass wir diese
unterstützung nicht bekommen und das
zweite natürlichen das ist muss druck
aufgebaut werden auf das weißrussische
regime und das ist bis jetzt noch nicht
gelungen
die frage ist ob diese
wirtschaftssanktionen überhaupt so wie
sie sind daher sehr optimistisch ich
sagen jemand wo der gasherd der gashahn
zugedreht würde dann würde auch diese
kriegsmaschinerie nicht mehr weiter
gekühlt werden und zu sagen und bildlich
gesprochen andere sagen na ja also
jemand der so wenig rücksicht auf die
wirtschaftlichen auf die eigene
bevölkerung nimmt und auch wirklich
wirtschaftliche zuständen der druck
teilt geld und die inflation ist mir
egal so einfach ist das nicht guckt sich
das ist ja ganz klar dieser zusammenhang
wenn mehr ein größeres größeres militär
etat vorhandenes wie bei den usa da kann
man sich auch militärisch mehr erlauben
in die andere richtung geht geht das
genauso wenn es keine tag gibt da kann
man sich militärisch nicht viel leisten
das ist ganz klar durch diese verkäufe
an öl und gas finanziert sich russland
diesem krieg und wenn es diesen diese
verkäufe nicht mehr gibt sie sagen man
könnte rubel drucken dann explodiert die
inflation selbst wenn die soldaten
einfach nur auf befehl weiter kämpfen
würden sie brauchen trotzdem munition
sie brauchen trotzdem ausrüstung und die
wird es dann nicht mehr geben das sind
natürlich ganz klare zusammenhänge das
kann man gar nicht abstreiten bestreiten
deswegen das muss gemacht werden wenn
sie sagen die ukraine muss diesen krieg
gewinnen
diesen ein solcher sieg aus dann putin
abzieht und kapituliert dass man sich
schwer vorstellen es gibt mehrere
möglichkeiten die eine ist natürlich
russland gibt auf oder ob es dann kann
den krieg nicht mehr weiter führen dass
wir wahrscheinlich noch die bessere
möglichkeit deswegen plädieren wir auch
für diese sanktionen für das dem wagen
wir wollen natürlich unser unsere
territoriale integrität weiter
verteidigen darum geht es einzig und
allein für uns und diese gebiete werden
wir niemals aufgeben die jetzt schon
besetzt sind deswegen dass wir dann auch
der das ende von diesem krieg wenn wir
diese gebiete zurück bekommen und wenn
russland diesen krieg nicht mehr
weiterführen kann weil es sich diesen
krieg nicht mehr leisten können wie hat
man sich das vorzustellen herr putin das
fällt schwer sich das bildlich
vorzustellen dass herr putin sagt war
irgendwie ein fehler ich gehe jetzt mal
dann doch wieder zurück deswegen musste
vor die tatsache gestellt werden es kann
einfach darf einfach nicht mehr die
möglichkeit haben ja und die besucher
diesen krieg weiter zu bedarf ich dass
wir die frage ist werden wo der druck
her kommt also ich glaube dass putin
kein einsehen haben wird darum über
diese muss wirklich sagen ich liebe
finde langsam diese appelle
fast schon peinlich weil zu glauben man
könnte ihnen jetzt mit guten worten wenn
du mir das sagt so habe ich mir noch
nicht gedacht dass er dann aufhören mit
aber ich glaube trotzdem und
gleichzeitig das es nur in russland
passieren kann und da gibt es eigentlich
zwei es sind hoffnung und das eine ist
das über die zeit es wird ein auszehrung
skript sei mit hohen mit zerstörung in
der ukraine aber es wird russland stark
ausziehen und dass die bevölkerung die
ja nicht überzeugt dass von diesem krieg
die der staatspropaganda ausgesetzt ist
nicht im lauf der zeit wenn sie die
wirtschaftlichen folgen zu spüren
bekommt es wird ein defektes wäre ein
effektes energie im august
protestiert die verwandten die mütter
die felder die geschwister von tausenden
von 18 19 jährigen rekruten sagen jetzt
reicht es ist genug putin oder auch im
militär die befehle nicht mehr
ausgeführt werden also das sind schon
zwei punkte die kann keiner voraussagen
aber sie können sich entwickeln im laufe
einer auszehrung die auf russischer
seite stärker sein wird als die ukraine
nicht das wäre also die hoffnung einer
palastrevolte genau das will ich nur
kurz kommentieren wenn wir um dieses
handelns immer wenn es darum geht das
wird ja auch nicht daten nicht nur dazu
dass der krieg nicht mehr weiterlaufen
können sondern auch dass die repressive
maschine innerhalb russlands die zu
dieser unterdrückung geführt hat dass
keiner protestieren kann dass die leute
nicht auf die straße gehen dass keiner
weiß weist und dass die polizei
unglaublich massiven ein massives der ta
hat und alles unterdrückt das kann ja
auch nicht mehr fortgeführt werden denn
wenn das darf jetzt kommen deswegen die
erfolgen somit beide ziele gleichzeitig
einerseits wir stoppen den krieg
andererseits führen wir auch zu einer
demokratischen entwicklung innerhalb
russlands führen dazu dass dieses system
das autoritäre system aus dem
gleichgewicht kommt und mit dem
zukünftigen demokratisch in russland
kann man vielleicht auch reden aber ich
habe gerade das russland ist dann weiter
in die seen werden ob wir alles
gleichzeitig machen müssen weil also was
ich vorher auch sagt ein krieg ist
politisch und militärisch na also wir
müssen nicht eine politische und eine
militärische niederlage russlands
gleichzeitig erweitern natürlich die
militärische heute erst mal vorrangig
findet in die ukraine sagt wir wollen
nicht der nato beitreten hatte ihn schon
mal etwas wo er nach hause gehen kann
überhaupt kann und wie ich habe mein
ziel erreicht
abzug zumindest aus dem weiten teilen
der ukraine und dann kommt der zweite
teil ich denke weil man jetzt über
eskaliert und dann auf dem regime change
regierungswechsel und nicht
systemwechsel sogar in russland
gleichzeitig in ausdruck dann glaube ich
dass mir das team hinauf ich würde das
sequenzieren also quasi erst das eine
und dann das andere also wenn ich da
eine andere meinung gerne
also
ich hab ich habe im laufe der letzten
zehn tage meine meinung geändert und ich
habe sie geändert weil wegen der das
nicht nur zur nur uns sondern
vernichtungskrieges des rücksichtslosen
maßlosen vernichtungskrieg und variiert
vorlesen kaum noch den den putin da
veranstaltet darf ich daran erinnern
dass wir für wesentlich weniger
anderswo interveniert haben in bosnien
im kosovo und in libyen und wir haben es
wir sagen es nur deshalb wir tun es nur
deshalb hier nicht und das weißbuch den
ganz genau wegen der nuklearwaffen aber
was da passiert ist grauenvoll es wird
die lebensgrundlage der gesamten ukraine
zerstört da bleibt kein stein auf dem
anderen und ein viertel der ukrainischen
bevölkerung von 40 millionen 10
millionen sagt der un
flüchtlingskommissar ist bereits
entweder intern diskutiert also
sogenannte internally displaced persons
oder geflohen über die grenzen hinweg
und es ist zu befürchten dass es noch
sehr viel mehr werden die frage ist ob
das ob diese das sozusagen bis ins
unendliche fortgesetzt für
irgendjemanden erträglich ist im westen
ich würde sagen nein und deshalb glaube
ich dass wir darüber nachdenken sollten
wie wir den druck auf dem kessel im
kreml bestärken können beschleunigen
können ja und ich würde das etwas anders
artikulieren als sie oder sie ich glaube
auch dass der demokratische wandel in
russland für uns wünschenswert ist aber
vermutlich in weiter ferne worum es
momentan nur gehen kann es die
kosten-nutzen-rechnung derjenigen zu
ändern die putin stützen im allerersten
die sogenannten silowiki die harten
männer für die es geht um russlands
status in der welt russlands respekt
russland ansehen das glaube ich können
wir sagen hat putin ihr kriegsverbrecher
bereits alles zerstört diese männer
müssen sich fragen was bleibt uns
eigentlich noch und da würde ich den
druck überall wo wir können diplomatisch
wirtschaftlich militärisch mithilfe an
die ukraine erhöhen so dass die das tier
zum schluss kommen dass putin für sich
nicht mehr gut ist und was der
unterschied zu unserer auffassen naja
der unterschied ist zunächst mal haben
dass also erstens was also wir beide
sind uns eigentlich darüber dass es dass
es nur von innen heraus geschehen kann
aber ist das beeindruckte aber genau
aber mein argument ist man muss jetzt
wirklich alle register ziehen und unter
anderem habe ich hab dann heute den
aufruf unterzeichnet
von einigen leuten haben wir beide
unterzeichnet genau ich habe mich damit
wirklich schwer getan weil ich dass das
argument der bundesregierung ernst nehme
mit der durchhaltefähigkeit der
deutschen wirtschaft an der deutschen
bevölkerung aber ich glaube es geht
nicht anders ich glaube ich ein bisschen
jetzt handeln und wir müssen ganz starke
signale setzen die auch psychologisch
wirken aber der aufruf ist eines den wir
beide unterzeichnen wir haben heute für
ein umfassendes sofort ist in der die
änderungen auch frau wolle das ist ja
auch das was die osteuropäer was die
balken fordern wie isoliert steht
deutschland dann dort neben den
niederlanden und italien in dem es immer
noch sich sozusagen dagegen verwehrt und
sagt das machen wir auf keinen fall er
scholz hat das heute noch mal gesagt als
er sagt da ja so dass mit den rubeln er
hat so eine art doppelte botschaft an
einen mutigen geschickt und gesagt also
dass mit diesem rubeln das schauen wir
uns die verträge angehört das kann er
eigentlich vergessen das machen wir
jetzt erstmal weiter in euro aber
gleichzeitig auch wir machen kein
embargo österreich sagt auch wir machen
kein embargo
hier bei aller geschlossenheit der
europäischen union im moment wird diese
diskussion nicht besonders ehrlich
geführt das muss man konstatieren
besonders laut ist ja polen an dem punkt
was ich natürlich verstehen kann ich
kann sehr viele dieser argumente
nachvollziehen nur polen ist eines der
länder das sehr stark abhängig ist von
russischen energielieferungen und wenn
sie dann
hinter verschlossenen türen oder auf den
korridoren mal darüber reden wo denn die
polen dann nachher ihre energie ihr
kriegen wollen wenn man ein solches
embargo durchführt dann heißt es das
soll die europäische union ihnen zur
verfügung stellen nun ist es so dass in
der gesamten europäischen union die
abhängigkeit von russischem gas über 40
prozent liegt bei der kohle noch höher
beim öl bei etwa 25 prozent
also
das ist das ist dann nicht mehr
vorstellbar also das sind dass das sind
nicht nur deutsche wirtschaftliche
interessen die dann die dann
beeinträchtigt werden da gehen wirklich
die europäischen volkswirtschaften
ziemlich in die knie was auch nicht
ehrlich ist zum beispiel frankreich
es gibt sehr viele lng terminals an der
spanischen küste
aber frankreich leitet dieses gas seit
vielen jahren nicht durch frankreich
durch nach kontinentaleuropa
die vermutung liegt nahe um die ja die
französische
monopolstellung von edf electricité de
france und dem französischen atomstrom
nicht zu beeinträchtigen also an dieser
stelle rufen viele im moment laut nach
dem embargo sind aber selbst dann nicht
bereit die konsequenzen dafür zu tragen
bzw haben völlig illusorischen
vorstellungen davon wie das abgepuffert
werden könnte
wollen wir als drittes noch mal schauen
auf das was ja gleichzeitig passiert
also es wird einerseits gekämpft
gleichzeitig versucht sich die eu zu
sortieren und eine gemeinsame stimme zu
finden mehr oder weniger und es wird
verhandelt
wie ernsthaft sind diese verhandlungen
moment zwischen der ukraine und russland
das ist jetzt noch nicht hochrangig von
denen die sich dort gegenüber sitzen
genau also wir sind eher pessimistisch
gestimmt wir sehen nicht wirklich dass
ich das was auf dem schlachtfeld
passiert mit diesen verhandlungen
entdeckt oder das ist nämlich zusammen
passt also die einerseits wird der krieg
intensiviert das läuft die vorbereitung
auf eine neue offensive zu von
russischer seite andererseits sehen die
von frieden also ich glaube es ist alles
nur ein täuschungsmanöver von russischer
seite um den west zu zeigen die sind
bereit frieden zu schließen und der
frieden es ja schon hier bald da
deswegen lohnt es sich auch gar nicht
mehr noch mehr sanktionen einzuführen
das bringt ja auch nicht mehr weiter
druck auszuüben wir sind ja schon fast
beim frieden der krieg ist zu ende das
ist die nachricht die dann damit auch
gesendet wird und den westen ich glaube
darum geht es auch an erster stelle es
gibt natürlich bestimmte punkte und die
werden noch besprochen manche von denen
sind nicht so schwer da kann man sich
relativ einfach einigen wir können über
den neutralen status der ukraine reden
solange er sicherheitsgarantien zugibt
wir können über die sprache reden da gab
es niemals irgendwelche probleme das ist
alles frei erfunden von russischer seite
aber es gibt natürlich auch punkte die
werden niemals besprochen werden sowie
die territoriale integrität unseres
landes wie drinnen geben sie nicht her
und wie einen separaten natürlich und
selbst wenn sie die menschen dort fragen
die wollen auch nicht in russland
bleiben deswegen das wird überhaupt
nicht gesprochen man muss sich ist das
stichwort sicherheitsgarantien das ist
glaube in dem zusammenhang ganz wichtig
bei dir gab es ja schon mal also wenn
man ins budapester memorandum denkmals
hat 94 als der ukraine ihre atomwaffen
abgegeben hatte da gab es auch
sicherheitsgarantien die sind wie wir
jetzt sehen das papier eigentlich nicht
wert auf dem sie standen also welche art
von sicherheitsgarantien kann denn der
westen könnte die nato
der ukraine geben ohne sich zum nato
mitglied zu machen gut das können wir
jetzt noch nicht genau sagen das wird
dir gerade besprochen aber wir können
uns vorstellen dass hauptsächlich geht
es ja nur darum dass auch russland
unsere territoriale integrität
akzeptiert anerkennt und dass wir auch
von ihnen sicherheit kommentieren
bekommen und die dann von allen anderen
abgesichert werden der türkei zum
beispiel oder auch von nato staaten
natürlich so einfach ist das nicht
natürlich sagen sie dann direkt dann
heißt es aber dass die nato einen direkt
konflikt mit russland angreifen könnte
deswegen wird darüber gesprochen wir
haben ja noch keine einigung aber es ist
das glatte glatte gegenteil von dem
warum putin krieg führt
er kann ja gerade nicht dulden dass sich
irland entwickelt
hat
runde gar nicht so viel gegen die nato
sondern hat vielmehr fürchtet er die
europäische union weil du und wenn dann
sozusagen weil dann die die weil wenn
die ukraine europäisch wird wenn sie
marktwirtschaft nicht demokratisch
rechtsstaatlich wird wird sie einen
erfolg und wenn das dann noch
abgesichert wird sicherheitspolitisch
durch die nato dann wäre dieser status
gesichert und er wäre sozusagen eine
alltägliche provokation für putin denn
es dauert ja nicht lange dass die russen
putin fragen wie kann das eigentlich
sein jedes land entwickelt sich die
polen die balten jetzt auch die ukraine
nur wir haben immer noch eine korrupte
unfähige führung und unser land
modernisiert sind ich habe lassen das
ist die machtfrage an ihnen lassen auch
so doch noch über die sicherheits
garantien geben bei wenn wir jetzt auf
verhandlungen und gucken man kann auch
erstmal fragen ist überhaupt schon der
zeitpunkt für verhandlungen da also man
sich die die die wahrheiten der
internationalen konfliktforschung
anguckt dann am verhandlungen meistens
erst dann wirklich eine chance wenn
einer am boden liegt oder dann beide
keine chance mehr auf den sieg sind da
sind ja im moment eigentlich noch
gefragten überfahrenen sollte natürlich
trotzdem weil verhandlung ist ja eine
form von kommunikation und so lange
geredet wird irgendwas lernt man dabei
ja immer ne und man sagt halt so in der
lage doch aber das ist halt so dass
irgendwie sie hatten gerade die
konfliktforschung angesprochen es gibt
quasi ein ausdruck dass eine konflikt
uhr gibt na also jeder konflikt hat
seine eigene tempo realität seinen
eigenen zeitpunkt wo dann die
verhandlung besonders erfolgreich sind
aber bis dahin muss man ja auch erstmal
irritieren und positionen abstecken usw
also ich denke verhandeln auch wenn man
weiß das ist jetzt nicht der richtige
moment gekommen ist dass da kein
durchbruch zu erwarten ist ist trotzdem
sinnvoll ich würde es vielleicht nicht
widerspreche das treffen was präsent
sein lenski angedeutet hat mit putin
wird jetzt vielleicht gerade nicht
machen an seiner stelle es könnte sehr
nach hinten losgehen aber für sie den
skoda für ich vermute für suhl entgehen
könnte schlecht ausgehen wir vermuten
dass man diese ganzen gerüchte dass er
ermordet werden soll gibt ja auch solche
die möglichkeit dass er vielleicht auch
vor ein tribunal gestellt werden sollte
dann in russland oder so als sogenannter
nazi also das würde ich davon würde ich
abraten aber trotzdem weiter verhandeln
während auf dem schlachtfeld hat
weiterhin der patt situation
hat fakten geschaffen werden die er dann
auch wieder die psychologie beeinflussen
also für putin ist dass gerade auch eine
schwierige situation wäre es nicht so
klingen als würden leid tun aber er ist
mit dem rücken an die wand die ganze
rhetorik alles was passiert auch auf dem
schlachtfeld heißt für ihn tatsächlich
er ist nicht in einer guten situation
und deswegen kommt ja auch nicht so klar
rhetorik darin aber da ist zum beispiel
der frühere schachweltmeister garri
kasparow sagt also wenn man sich
gedanken macht darüber dass man solche
angst hat dass jemand verliert und
deshalb erst recht etwas wahnsinniges
tut dann ist man eigentlich auch schon
teil dieses dieses dieses
psychologischen spiels geworden also ich
sehe einfach keine verhandlungslösung
die die stabil ist